The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Right, so now
I'm going to walk you
through some examples.
And just so you know where
this stuff is-- so you all
have your LLGrid accounts.
And in your LLGrid accounts--
and I'm looking over here
because these people are
going to check to make sure
I don't say anything wrong.
So this is, by the way,
this is [INAUDIBLE]
over here and Julie Mullin.
They are our expert consultants,
PhDs in computational science,
that help you all.
And we're all eternally
grateful to them
for helping us get all
this technology to work.
So if you go to
your LLGrid account,
there should be a link
in there called Tools.
This is where all the
software is that we
provide as part of LLGrid.
And there'll be one
called d4m_api in there.
So there'll be a
folder just like this.
And just so you know-- so all
the lectures are there for you.
And I am putting them all
in for public release.
And all the software we're going
to post on the internet too.
And so just make
it easier for you
to use, use with
your government-- use
with your sponsors,
use with your projects,
all that kind of stuff.
We try and do that so that
people aren't constantly asking
us, well, what can I share?
It's like, I'm going to
put it on the internet.
So there you go.
We want to focus on the
examples directory here.
The order of the examples
is numerical order.
So we are going to
go through examples
in the folder called one
and then two and then three.
And this really corresponds
to kind of the first three
lectures, then the
next three lectures,
then the next
three lectures, OK?
And so today, we're going to
go in here to this first one.
And then here is kind of like
the first three of those three.
We're going to go
and we're going
to review this set here, OK?
So these are the-- the examples
of have this sort of-- they
basically take the
first two letters
of the folder-- in this case,
[INAUDIBLE] intro AI 1234.
Those are the actual examples.
If you see other files in there,
those are supporting files.
You don't run those directly.
So I'm going to start my--
I'm going to-- I always run
MATLAB from the shell.
Other people run
it from the IDE.
I'm going to create
a shell here.
[INAUDIBLE] folder.
I'm going to start my MATLAB up.
This will take a
minute because we're
reusing 2012B, which is a little
bit slower on this computer.
All right, there we go.
And you'll be pleased
to know I develop
all the [? D form ?] software
on this little computer.
And people are going,
well, why don't you
get a big giant workstation
to develop your programs on?
It's like, well, because
if it feels OK for me
on this computer, I
know that most of you
have much better computers.
And it will feel-- should feel
very, very, very good for you.
All right, so we're
in the folder.
And I'm just going to run the
first program-- AI1_SetupTEST.
Actually, before we
even get into that,
the first thing you're
going to want to do
is check before you run
this that your D4M code has
been properly set up.
The simplest way to do that
is when you start MATLAB,
if you type help D4M
and you get a list
of all the functions
in D4M, then
that means that your
path is set up properly.
And this is just a list of
all the different functions.
We break them down
in different types.
You've got a little sort
of like how to set up here,
although a lot of this stuff
isn't-- is written for more
people on the outside world.
And we go through
all the functions
and we categorize the functions.
You know, some are
functions that we really
expect to use all the time.
Some are functions
that you might use once
in kind of rare instances.
And then we also have
functions like, look,
you really-- they're there.
They're in the library.
These are really not meant
for you to use, though.
They're really internal
supporting functions.
But they're there
in the library.
All right, so that's the
first thing you want to check
is to make sure that's set up.
If you have any issues, send
email to grid-help@ll.mit.edu
and the people will help
you in and check it out.
And don't be surprised if
some of you do have an issue.
This is the first time
we've really rolled it out
to such a large audience.
And so we absolutely
expect people to have
little things that will pop up.
All right, so I'm going to
run the first example here.
I should say we also have
tested all the stuff.
For those of you who are utterly
averse to commercial software,
depending on your
religious preferences,
we also run with
GNU Octave, which
is the GPL version
for those of you
who refuse to run
non-free software.
And so this-- all
this stuff should also
work with that as well
just for those people who
prefer to use that
type of environment.
But generally,
MATLAB-- you know,
it's pretty available here.
And so we certainly
encourage you to use that.
So we're going to run
the first test here.
AI1_SetupTEST-- Go.
Yay, it worked.
It's embarrassing when you're
recording and these don't work.
So I'm going to walk you through
some really rudimentary stuff
here in this example.
So one of the things in D4M
that you're dealing with a lot
is lists of strings--
long list of strings,
millions of distinct strings.
Now, MATLAB has
data structures that
do support lists of strings,
cell arrays being one of them.
There's other data structure
that you can use to do that.
They naturally support these.
But they tend to be very
memory intensive and very slow.
And so given our
whole thing here
is we have a real
focus on performance,
me giving you a
great tool that's
1,000 times slower than other
techniques is not very helpful.
So we are going to be
dealing with list of strings
all the time.
And so in D4M, a list of strings
is a row vector of characters,
OK?
I've highlighted here.
And the last character in the
row vector is the delimiter.
In this case, it's the comma.
You're at the end.
That is the delimiter.
It can be whatever
you want it to be.
It can be semicolon.
It can be a dash.
It can be a space.
I tend to recommend new line,
which is ASCII character 10--
very safe delimiter.
But whatever that last character
is, that's the limiter.
And you could have different
lists, different strings
with different delimiters.
It should handle those
situations just fine.
But within a list
of strings, it needs
to be that-- that last
character will be the delimiter.
So I'm actually
creating here a list.
I'm going to creating a
set of triples here-- r,
which is the rows, c,
which is the columns, v,
which is the values.
And so I have an
r, which is this.
I have a set of c
here, which is this.
Vector here and then
a list of values--
and the values in
this case are just
appending the row and the
column together with a dash.
And all three of
these use the comma
as-- it's the last character--
as the delimiter, all right?
And now I'm going to create
an associative array, which
is the fundamental
data structure in D4M.
It's what allows us to
bridge linear algebra
and strings together.
So this is a constructor command
for an associative array--
so Assoc.
And then we give it
a list of row keys.
These are called-- we often call
them keys-- list of column keys
and a list of string values.
And this construct the
associative array a.
And in MATLAB, since
I haven't terminated
this with a semicolon, it
will now will print out
the list of triples.
So now you can see the list of
triples we can construct here
was row a, column a, value a-a,
row aa, column a, value aa-a,
and I won't read the whole list.
Yes, Darryl.
AUDIENCE: Question. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That is an artifact
of this printing out display.
It will show you the delimiter
that you actually used here
just as-- and it's
good to know that you--
AUDIENCE: It's not really there.
PROFESSOR: It's
not really there.
Yeah, I mean, it's there
and it's not there.
But it's showing
you the delimiter.
And after a while, you just
kind of learn to ignore that.
The only time this does become
a little bit of an issue
is that that is the
newline character.
Then the formatting
gets a little bit--
and we've actually
built in routines
that allow you to take
an associative array,
replace the delimiter with
something nicer in one command
so that you can print it out and
doesn't look so crazy if you're
using a new line.
Typically, though, you
tend to be doing this print
out command on small things.
So it's fine.
So that's the whole
list, you see there,
of all the different entries.
If you use the disp
command, it will actually
display the internal structure
of the associative array.
And an associative array object
in D4M has four fields total.
That's it.
We do everything with
just four fields.
And the four fields
are a set of row keys.
This is a lexicographically
sorted list
of the unique row keys.
And it's stored
as a string list.
So in this case, we had
six unique row keys.
And we have six entries
in this row string list.
Likewise, the column
is the same thing.
We have these six
unique entries.
And you see they inherit
the delimiter that
was passed into them.
If I'd used different ones, you
would see different delimiters.
And then the value, which
is another list that
shows all the different
strings, OK, and then
a matrix, which shows--
which is a six by six matrix.
So this is a six by
six associative array.
And this is the pointer.
Basically, the value stored in a
six by six sparse matrix points
to the index of the value.
So you can view that as
a pointer to the values.
And this is how
we can have values
that are actually strings.
That may not be quite clear.
There's an easier
way to do this.
So we have a little routine
function here called
displayFull, which produces a
nice tabular view of the data.
So here's the row keys, the
column keys, and the values.
And you see this was the
matrix I constructed.
You had a full first
column and a full first row
and then values
along the diagonal.
And then what we're going to
do is we want to save this.
We want to write it out.
So we're going to
write it out to-- we
have a function
[INAUDIBLE] assoc to CSV.
So I pass an associative array.
I give it the row terminator and
the column separator and a file
name and we'll
write that data out
to a CSV file, which
is very convenient.
[INAUDIBLE] actually hide that.
You can see here
is the CSV file.
So you can look at it.
There's the CSV file.
You can zoom in on that for you.
Can you see?
There we go.
Those are our six rows, six
columns against first row,
against first column, and
our diagonal, all right?
All right, so
let's go back here.
Now let's go to
our next example,
which is going to be AI2.
And now we're going
to talk about how--
we sort of described how we put
data into an associative array.
We're now going to talk about
how we query it or get data out
of the associative array.
And one thing that's very
nice about the queries
that I will show you as
we get to the later parts
of the [? course ?]
we do databases,
whether you're querying
an associate array that's
in memory or binding to
a table, it's the same.
We try and make it so
that almost everything you
would do in an associate array,
you could also do on a table.
So you can write your
programs in associative arrays
and then switch a
couple things and now it
should also work on tables
in the database the same way.
And so we try and
preserve that concept.
The only difference is that a
table [? in ?] databases just
can be much, much bigger than
an associative array you would
have in your memory space.
All right, so you're
going to run that.
That's the next example.
So the first thing
we did is when
we wrote out the
associate array,
we're going to read it back in.
So we have a nice
function here called
ReadCSV that reads CSV files.
Just so you know,
Microsoft Excel
does write out a
non-standard CSV file.
Microsoft Excel
[INAUDIBLE] common-- that
is, if you have a row that is
empty after a certain point,
it won't write out those commas,
which is technically probably
not conformant with the
official CSV format,
although I don't know there is
a sufficiently written down CSV
format, right?
You can describe it in one line.
So you just have to
be careful about that.
If you see this issue, people
write out a CSV from Excel.
And if there's an empty
last-- if it's last row is not
fully dense or if its last
column is not a dense column,
you can get this issue and
it will screw this stuff up.
We also don't support
quoted strings.
Way to do that, though,
is to create a TSV file.
So put tabs in there.
And we support tab-- just, if
you just call this a TSV file,
when you write it
out, you can have
your separator via tab
instead of column, a comma,
and then you're all good.
And so that's how
we support that.
So we're going to now-- so
that's how you read it in.
And now we're going
to do a whole bunch
of different queries.
These are all what are
relatively complicated queries.
So the first one here
is get me rows a and b.
So if I pass in a string
list just like the-- whoops,
didn't want to do that.
Let's see here.
We pass in a string list of the
same type that I have before.
And I just say this exact
same type of indexing
that we normally have in
MATLAB where you're like,
I want to get it a set of rows.
I give it a set of rows.
And so this says,
get me rows a and b.
And give me the
whole row-- colon--
use the standard MATLAB syntax
that colon means full row.
Likewise, if a was a
binding to a table,
it would deliver the exact
same query to the database
and return the exact same
thing in associative array.
Here's another more
complicated that says get me
all rows containing a.
So our wild card character
is a little liberal here.
It will just give you
anything containing an a.
It doesn't really respect
beginnings or endings
or anything like that.
It's kind of a
regular expression.
And this says get any row
containing a and column's one
through three.
So we can use numerical indexes.
Sometimes, you're
just like, I don't
care what the row keys are.
Just give me the first 10
columns or the first 10 rows.
And that will return this, OK?
This is one feature that does
not work on all databases.
Some database have a
concept-- the numerical index
of a column.
And some databases do not.
So it's dependent on
the actual database.
Here's another one.
This is a range query.
So if you remember in MATLAB,
if you do colon and two values,
it gives you a range.
So we can do a range query here.
So a-- give me all
columns a through b.
If you really
wanted to just get--
we have something called a
starts with, which is something
like-- a lot of
times, you'll be like,
I want to just get the
rows or the columns that
begin with a certain string.
So we have a little
shorthand routine here
that constructs that for you.
So this says, get me all
rows starting with a and c.
Likewise, I can do the
same thing with columns.
I can say get me
columns a and b.
I can say get me all columns
that contain a with columns--
with rows one through three.
Like I said, I can do
column ranges here.
I can say, give me
all columns a to b.
Likewise, I can do the
starts with command
as well as give me all
columns starting with a or c.
And then finally, I
think this kind of fun,
we can actually
query the values.
Again, this is a
feature that's not
in-- [? it's ?] supported
with the database.
But it is supported with
the associate array, which
is if I say get me all-- return
an associative array were
all the values are greater than
b-- I'm sorry, less than b, OK?
So let me just show you
what that looks like.
So this was that query.
And this is what it looks like.
So I do display
a-- and you see now
we don't have any
values that begin
with a b-- all the values, OK?
Another thing that
we should notice here
is that this is now a three
by three matrix, not a six
by six matrix.
Associative arrays
never store an empty row
or an empty column.
That is a big difference
between traditional sparse
linear algebra and
associative arrays.
In sparse linear
algebra, you could
have a row of all
zero-- an empty row
or an empty column, not
an associative arrays.
Associative arrays,
you either have--
there's going to be-- if
you have a row or column,
it's going to have
an [? entry-- ?] yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So
basically, all it does--
so it's basically-- so if we
had a value to begin with,
c, that would also
not be included.
So it's basically--
lexographically, we
compare the value aa with b.
And we say, is it
lexographically before b?
If so, it satisfies
the condition.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, yes.
So that's the policy
that we [? made-- ?]
so strictly, the algebra
of associate arrays
doesn't require
lexographical ordering.
That's an implementation fact.
It's a very important
implementation fact.
We are constantly maintaining
lexicographical order
inside the data structure.
Yeah, Darryl?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right,
yeah-- three by six,
sorry, three by six.
Yes, yes-- because these
are full here, right?
But you see that the ones--
none of the ones with b in it
happened because they
didn't satisfy criteria.
So therefore, they're empty.
And so therefore-- so just
very important thing to know.
All right, moving on
here to the next--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You define
other [? orderings. ?]
The mathematics would
no doubt admit that.
It's really backed in, though,
into the implementation.
I mean, because we rely on
the MATLAB sort command--
and as far as I know,
that does not allow
you to have other orderings.
Now, you could
obviously do rehashed.
You could hash your rows
and keys to some other thing
and then have an associate array
that maps those back and forth.
And in fact, people do that
all the time and just have--
and you could do that.
But that's how-- and if
you really, really want
the order-- the
main thing, though,
is to kind of think
of it, though,
is that the ordering
doesn't really matter.
It's really a device that
allows me to do fast lookups.
And you shouldn't really
care about the ordering.
So let's move on to
the next example.
So actually-- so
we're going to do AI3.
So now we're going to do
some math on this stuff, OK?
So here we go.
All right, so once
again, I read in my data
that I constructed
in the first example.
The values of that
data are strings.
But if I want to do
math, sometimes I
don't want to do
math on strings.
Sometimes, I want to
do math on numbers.
So in D4M, the associate
arrays can also
be numbers, which can be
very convenient for doing
mathematical operations.
And so what we have here
is we have this command
called dblLogi, which
is a shorthand for--
and it's kind of cut
off here-- applying
logical to the associate array,
which takes all the values
and converts them just
to a zero or a one--
basically throws
away the strings.
Or if it was a numeric value,
just [INAUDIBLE] are you there?
You're a one.
You're not there, you're
a zero or you're empty.
And then since we
can't do arithmetic
on logicals in MATLAB, we have
to bump them back into doubles.
So we do this so
often, we've actually
made a little shorthand
here where we call dblLogi.
And you'll see that all the
time in the class because I just
don't like to type all
the characters [INAUDIBLE]
writing double logical
gets very redundant.
Now, if we go and look
at that data again,
we see when you do
displayFull that
instead of where
before we had values
of these various strings,
we just now have numbers--
just ones.
So that's convenient.
Now I can do arithmetic on them.
So let me do the
first thing here.
One of the things
I might want to do
is sum all the rows-- so
the MATLAB sum command.
It's basically-- you're giving
it essentially the dimension
to eliminate.
The first dimension we want
to eliminate or sum over
is the row dimensions.
So that means it's
summing up all these rows.
It's basically squishing the
matrix and summing them up.
And now we have a new
associative array,
which is essentially a one
by six associative array.
You see now that the
row key is empty.
Because when we
sum, the definitions
of the rows sort
of kind of go away.
So we don't-- you don't have
to have strings to be your row
keys.
You can have numeric row keys.
Just leave the row entry empty.
But there are some
cautions with that as well.
So when we sum that and
you see [INAUDIBLE] we
have all the
columns, the values,
because they're not
strings, are just
stored in this a matrix itself.
And you see that we had six
and two and two and two and two
and two.
So when we sum these up, that's
exactly what you would expect.
Moving along, we
can do the columns.
So here I'm going to sum.
And then I'm going to do display
full, which is the same as just
kind of listing it.
And we see here we now sum the--
compressed all the columns.
So we have a column vector.
And this shows the row
labels of that column vector.
We now have a new column
label, which is just one.
And then you see the actual
values there-- again,
a very useful thing.
People do this all
the time summing
of their rows and columns.
Let's do a simple join.
So I'm going to say give me
a column vector A. Get me
another column vector b, right?
And now I'm going to
join these two together.
Now, I could just do aa and ab.
But I'd get an empty matrix.
The reason is because it
would attempt to do the joins
and they would have
different column labels.
And so when we do joins,
we're intersecting
the two sets of row and
column keys together.
And if they have sep-- those
are just separate columns.
They add them together,
they have no intersection.
However, if we have this
function called no call, which
is actually blows
away the column
and basically gives them all,
in this case a column value one,
we can now add them together.
And we can actually
find where these two
things have a common value.
So that's a fairly
simple way to do a join.
This is something called a facet
search, which basically says,
all right, I'm going to
join these things together.
So I'm going to create
a column vector.
But then I'm going to
transpose that over here.
So I transpose it.
And then I'm going
to multiply it back
with the original matrix.
This gives me a count of
essentially all-- given
all columns, all
rows that contained--
had an entry in column a and B,
can you now sum up their rows?
And this is a fairly--
this is actually
the mathematical basis of, if
you ever do in Google search
it does auto-find,
it's essentially
trying to do this
type of operation.
It's trying to guess what the
next most popular topic would
be.
And this is essentially--
this mathematical operation
does that kind of thing.
We actually have a bunch
of applications in lab
that use this quite heavily.
And I can display the
transpose of that--
so to make it a column vector.
And as you see here, we
have a bunch of columns here
and then values.
And then we can actually do
things like sum and normalize.
So we can divide.
So I'm going to normalize them.
You can display that.
You see now you get the
probabilities associated
with these things.
Just basically, you
can just kind of
go on your way doing math.
This shows essentially the
correlation of the columns
a and b.
But why not just do all
the correlations at once?
So I'll focus on here.
So we have this
function square in,
which is the same as a
transpose a but a little bit
faster if you're just squaring
something with itself.
I'm going to get the
diagonal of that.
So if I use this function Adj,
which stands for adjacency,
it'll just pop out that
a matrix by itself.
Whenever you use
Adj, you're getting
a straight sparse MATLAB matrix.
And you can do any
operation on that
that you want that
MATLAB supports.
So it's a really-- I
highly recommend that.
If you can't figure
out how to do it
with associate
arrays [INAUDIBLE]
just pop up that
adjacency matrix.
Do whatever you want.
And then you can just-- as long
as you didn't change the size,
you can just stuff it right
back in at essentially no cost.
So this is basically
copies that field out.
And we're going to
get the diagonal.
The reason we want
to get the diagonal
is when we do correlations, we
always get this dense diagonal.
I want to eliminate that.
So I'm going to then now
take the adjacency matrix
of the original correlation
matrix, subtract the diagonal.
And then we have this
function [? putAdj, ?] which
is kind of the inverse
of Adj, which just says
I have an associative array.
Replace that a with this.
No checking, instantaneous
copy, very fast,
but make sure it's
the right size.
If it's the wrong size
or you've reoriented
the columns in some way
or the rows in some way,
then it won't make any sense.
So it's a little bit
of an advanced feature,
but it's a very powerful one.
You can pop stuff in and out of
these structures very quickly.
And that way, if you
ever need to do math
that we don't support, you
can just do that directly.
And so if we look
at that, we see
what you would expect-- a
nice correlation matrix here,
symmetric with no diagonal
and the counts of each one.
Right here-- so let me
move on to the next example
here, which is AI4.
And this just shows
you different ways
to construct associative
arrays, some of the various kind
of more degenerate cases.
So I have a bench [INAUDIBLE]
creating a string here
and a bunch of numeric values.
The point here is when you
construct an associative array,
one, we have full
support for all
these degenerate
empty conditions.
You give me anything
with any kind of empty,
we're going to return an
empty associative array.
MATLAB has outstanding
support for empty objects.
You can just keep on passing.
You don't have
to-- we basically--
what I'm saying is we
do a lot of checking.
If the thing is
empty, short circuit,
return an empty type of thing.
So you're not having
to constantly check
if something is empty or
not in order to proceed.
So that's what we do there.
That's just showing you
all these [? supported. ?]
In addition, you
can do mixed types.
So when you construct
an associative array,
if one of the values is a
scalar-- like, for instance,
you can have that.
You don't-- you know normally,
as in the MATLAB sparse
constructor, when you
give it a set of triples,
they all have to
be the same length.
Or any one of them can-- or
any of them can be scalars.
So this just says, I have
a bunch of columns strings,
a bunch of numeric values.
Oh and by the way, they
all have the same row.
So this is a very quick way
to construct a row vector.
I don't have to go and
replicate this a that many times
to make this work.
Likewise here, I could
have a numeric value
for the actual rows, a
string value for the columns.
And I want everyone to
have the same value.
They're all going to
have the value of a.
And you can do
variations on that theme.
So you do-- these are fast
ways to create row columns, row
vectors, or column
vectors or values
with all or constant
numeric value
and other types of
things like that.
And then we can just
display one of these.
And you see here-- I think it
was which one we displayed--
this first one, which is a row.
And you can see when you
display that, it just
has one value for the row.
These are the different columns.
These are the different values.
Then again, if we
display full, you
see in the tabular form
that's what you have.
So that brings us to the
end of the first lecture.
I'm happy to stay for questions
that people might have.
Please go and check out
your LLGrid account.
Copy the examples.
Don't try and work
out of the-- you'll
get, like, permission denied
errors and stuff like that.
Copy the examples to
your home directory.
Try and get your D4M working.
Try and run just
this first example.
Make sure it behaves the
same way that we had here.
And then send
email to grid-help.
And then as we get
into the next week,
we'll do homeworks that are a
little bit more substantive.
But this is just to make
sure the technology is
working for you.
And that's-- we'll
wrap it up there.
Thank you.